[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
21 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
A little bit tired after all
these weeks of a lot of action,
but yeah.
I'm very excited about
the interviews today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're going to have some
conversations that we recorded
back at GCP Next,
a couple of weeks
ago now, talking to the
people from Instrument,
who did the demos at the event.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So we interviewed three
people from Instrument.
We interviewed John Brown,
who is the technical director,
Violet Pena, who
worked on Vision API
for a very cool
demo for Emotobooth,
and then, Nick Tzaperas,
who worked on the QueryIt!,
which is the demo
used in BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There were pretty awesome demos.
I think it's going to be really
interesting to hear, like,
how they explored the APIs
and used the products,
what they learned, what
worked, and what didn't.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Those are all very
beautiful demos.
Like, you can tell that
they're pros at this.
But also, they're really
interesting in the way
they use our products.
So I think there are going to be
very interesting conversations.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
most definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
after that, we'll
have a question of the week.
And today, it's about
Deployment Manager.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're going to have a look
at how you can use variables
in Deployment Manager.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think it's
the first time we ever said
the words, Deployment Manager.
MARK MANDEL: I think so.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
excited about that, too.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But first,
let's go with the cool thing
of the week.
So we're going to be talking
about Stackdriver Error
Reporting.
So what's new in that?
MARK MANDEL: So as of a blog
post that came out yesterday,
we're pretty excited to
announce that if you need
a service to,
basically, aggregate
and collate the errors
that are happening
within your application, and I
guess there are probably some.
I'm sure everyone
else in our audience
has applications that
are completely perfect
and never error out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Mine are perfect.
MARK MANDEL: I believe so.
So we've had log aggregation
for a really long time.
You generally also want
some kind of service
to be, like, hey, all these
errors happen together.
They're all happening
at same time.
Maybe they only send
you a notification
when a new one pops up.
It handles those
sorts of things,
like, where is it coming from?
All that sort of stuff.
It's a lot easier to, sort
of, parse than being like,
let's go through all
the logs, looking
for keywords, things like that.
It's pretty cool.
And right now, it's
in beta, so, you know,
it comes for free,
which is pretty sweet.
If you're using App Engine,
though, you get it for free.
You don't have to
install any agents.
do anything special.
It's just ready to
go out of the box.
If you're on a computer
engine, you just
have to install a
[INAUDIBLE] agent,
and there are some tools
in there for sending errors
through to it.
But yeah, I think
it's pretty cool.
I'm pretty excited
with how it works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
The thing that I really like
is, whenever it actually
finds new errors-- you can,
of course, set these up
to match your preferences,
but it can actually
send you e-mails.
So you can,
basically, be on call
and enjoy your life
until the moment when
you get the e-mail saying, well,
enjoying your life is done now.
Go back to work.
But, yeah.
I think it's a
very useful feature
that I hope people will use.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I mean, it's not as sexy
as some of the things
that we've done in the
past, and as shiny, maybe.
But it's, sort of, one
of those glue pieces that
holds everything together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I could say it's
almost as sexy and shiny
as, probably, messaging.
MARK MANDEL: Like logging.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's like, yeah, when
it works, nobody cares.
MARK MANDEL: But when you
need it, you really need it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, exactly.
Cool.
So I think it's time to
go talk with our friends
from Instrument.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're going
to have three interviews, back
to back.
So enjoy them.
We're going to have, first,
John Brown, then Violet Pena,
and finally, Nick Tzaperas.
And then, we'll be back to talk
about the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds like fun.
We're joined today by somebody,
I think, a little special
to the conference.
JOHN BROWN: Oh, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: A little special.
A gentleman by the
name of John Brown.
I believe you're the
technical director?
JOHN BROWN: Yes, I'm
the technical director
at Instrument, from
Portland, Oregon.
And I oversaw the
development of the playground
experiences that all
the attendees have
been experiencing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So the playground experiences--
there is the Emotobooth.
JOHN BROWN: The
Emotobooth, right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There is the 360 Tour.
JOHN BROWN: The 360
Data Center Tour.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There's the BigQuery.
JOHN BROWN: And
there's the QueryIt!.
It's the BigQuery trivia game.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So let's
talk a little bit about them.
Why don't we start
with the Emotobooth?
MARK MANDEL: The
Emotobooth is awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Tell
us, what is this exactly,
and how did you make it?
JOHN BROWN: Sure.
So the Emotobooth is deceptive.
You think it's just going
to be a photo booth.
You walk up.
But all of a sudden,
the person who's
taking your photo isn't
just saying, smile.
They're saying, frown.
Show me some surprise.
Actually, show me some anger.
What do you got?
You got some anger?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JOHN BROWN: And you get
through joy, sorrow, anger,
and surprise.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Isn't that the seven
stages of grief or something?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN BROWN: Those are the
seven sins, the four sins.
And then, after you
get your photos taken,
you walk around the corner,
and instead of just seeing
a regular photo, you get to
see a close-up of your face.
It shows all the
landmarks of where
your eyebrows are, the corners
of your eyes, your mouth.
And then, it shows
you the sentiment.
It gets sent through the Google
Vision, the Cloud Vision API,
the face detection portion.
And it'll show the
likelihood of all
of the four different
sentiments that it already
had you go through.
So you get to see a cool
aura surround your face.
So if you had a very
likely joy, you're
gonna see a really fun
yellow halo burst around you,
or if you really could nail
that frown when they asked you
to frown, you can see a fun
blue shade that goes up.
MARK MANDEL: I particularly
am enamored with this.
We may have possibly changed
the title image on our Twitter
account for GCP Podcast--
JOHN BROWN: Oh, amazing.
MARK MANDEL: --to both
of us being surprised.
JOHN BROWN: You guys
did a group shot?
MARK MANDEL: We
did the two of us.
It was fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let
me show you right now,
but this is our new photo.
JOHN BROWN: Yeah.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
can find that if you go
to Twitter.com/GCPPodcast,
you will see both of us being
incredibly surprised.
MARK MANDEL: One thing I
love, and you do this well,
is not only did you
let people see it
on the images around
the corner, but also,
when you tweet it out, you've
got a gist there with, like,
all the data from Cloud Vision
API as well as all the images
that you took in
the photos as well.
JOHN BROWN: Exactly.
Yeah.
So you can explore the
photo and all the data
that's related to it.
It's all in one place.
You can, sort of,
compare and contrast
between the different pieces.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
I really liked it.
The second one that a lot of
people were very excited about
is the 360 Tour.
JOHN BROWN: Yeah.
So our company did the
planning of the actual 360
portion of it.
We didn't actually do the video.
A Google team did the internal
data center video for it.
But we, sort of, integrated it
with the rest of the playground
experience.
People would come
in, look at it,
get to see the
behind-the-scenes of the server,
that Google is finally
letting people see,
in a really cool way.
You get to see it
in-- I don't know,
it's probably,
about, 30 feet wide.
You can actually
feel like you're
standing inside of the server.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is pretty amazing.
I have personally
been at a data center,
and this is probably
the closest you can
get without working at Google.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I was pretty impressed
with the amount of stuff
that we're actually showing
inside the data center.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN BROWN: Yeah.
It's really neat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very cool.
One more question about the
last demo that we have is,
the BigQuery-- called, QueryIt!?
JOHN BROWN: QueryIt!.
QueryIt, exclamation point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I love the name.
MARK MANDEL: I haven't had
a chance to play with this.
So tell me about
what's the deal there.
JOHN BROWN: Yeah.
So essentially, what we did
is, we wrote 200 questions.
They're, sort of, trivia
questions-- things like,
what state mentions Velveeta
cheese the most on Reddit?
Or what musician's Wikipedia
page was visited most in 2015?
And what we've done is, we
have a ton of public data
sets for Reddit,
Wikipedia, GDELT,
and a couple others that we
have written queries for,
that when you type
in your answer,
it actually puts it into the
query, runs the query live.
There's a really
fun visualization
that has a visualized
model of what's happening
behind the scenes in BigQuery.
So it's not 100%
accurate, but it's
a really cool visual
representation
of what's happening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
looks really cool.
JOHN BROWN: Yeah.
And then, you get points
based on the accuracy
of your results.
And there are two
podiums, so you get
to play a friend or a stranger.
There's a little
bit of competition.
Maybe you can talk smack to
each other, back and forth,
but it's a lot of fun.
MARK MANDEL: So you're,
like, basically,
trying to guess what the
big data computation is
going to end up being?
JOHN BROWN: Exactly.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
actually got to play twice.
JOHN BROWN: How'd you do?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
first time, I won.
But it was kind of cheating,
because the first question
that I got was-- I think it was
from Stack Overflow or, maybe,
GitHub?
JOHN BROWN: Oh, yeah.
GitHub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was,
what is the language where
people mention more of Google?
And I'm a developer advocate for
Go, so that was, kind of, easy.
JOHN BROWN: Right, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
got 100% on that one.
And even though I wanted to
let the other person win,
because the last
question was, what
was the most popular
kitchen utensil on Wikipedia
last month?
I went with spork.
JOHN BROWN: How did you do?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Zero.
That was the point.
I wanted to lose,
and I still won.
And the second time, yeah,
I got destroyed by Sarah.
Sarah Robinson from our
team, she destroyed me
at every single question.
JOHN BROWN: Good.
[LAUGHTER]
That's fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah,
that was an awesome demo.
Tell us a little bit
about your experience
using the Cloud to
build these demos.
How was it?
JOHN BROWN: Sure.
So one of the really
interesting things
is, we got to use the Cloud
Vision API when it was still
in the alpha stage.
So we got to see what
it was going to be,
and we got to try all the
different features early on.
And as we were developing
the Emotobooth,
we got to try things like the
object detection or the label
detection.
We got to try the OCR.
We got to try landmarks.
We got to try all
these different things,
and we got to craft the
experience that we ended up
seeing, based on being able to
easily put all the images in,
run through it, get a bunch of
that data, and, sort of, like,
look at it, and figure out
what we wanted to do with it.
And we ended up going with
the sentiment analysis,
but we had things-- like, we
had giant cutouts of hot dogs,
and we're, like, can
we detect the hot dog?
We wanted to give people cowboy
hats and put them into a scene,
and is it going to
detect the cowboy hats?
We tried a bunch of
different things,
but the Cloud Vision API
was really great, even
in the alpha stage.
And then, the only thing that--
it only got better as it went.
We got to run more
queries on it,
we got to run more
hits on the API,
and it was a lot of fun to
develop a physical experience
around it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And you found it, I'm guessing,
like, a relatively easy API
to use.
Like, it wasn't difficult.
JOHN BROWN: Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
We built a tool to just
drag and drop images
into a web browser
in, about, half a day.
And we were up and running,
and we could see the output
and zoom in on the faces
where they were detected,
and get all the
sentiment analysis.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is
that tool ope source?
JOHN BROWN: So all of the tools
are going to be open-source,
probably, about, mid-April.
We rushed to get
everything here.
We've got a little bit technical
debt we need to take care of.
MARK MANDEL: I know
this very well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I can imagine.
Yeah.
We've been there.
JOHN BROWN: But, yeah.
All the tools and the
Emotobooth will be up.
We're going to be,
hopefully, going to IO,
so if anybody didn't get
to come and experience
either the Emotobooth
or QueryIt!
here at the next conference,
we may be at the IO Conference.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL: That'll be great.
That would be awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is great.
So tell us a little
bit about what you
thought about the conference.
I know you were really
busy building the demos,
but were you able to follow
a little bit of the keynote?
JOHN BROWN: So there
are so many people
wanting to go through
the Emotobooth,
that we didn't get to
really see the keynote.
But one thing that I will
say about the conference
that my team has gotten
to experience firsthand
is, going through the
Emotobooth-- as I said,
you're trying to get people
to do joy, anger, sorrow,
and surprise.
But essentially,
everybody's going through,
and there's so much
happiness and joy,
and people are smiling, having a
good time, being around people,
and learning about what's next,
that our historical screen is
skewed with a ton of
joy, even though we're
trying to get the emotions out
of people for the other things.
Basically, everybody's
here, having a great time,
and I mean, that's exactly
what you want to see.
MARK MANDEL: We have
statistical representation
of people having a good time.
JOHN BROWN: Yes.
We have data.
We have data on that now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
a good problem to have.
That is a good skew to have.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
Well, thank you so much, again,
John, for taking the time
to talk with us.
We know you're very busy today.
JOHN BROWN: Yeah I'm
gonna go back over there.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
JOHN BROWN: Thank you two.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you later.
JOHN BROWN: Bye.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
now with Violet Pena, one
of the developers
from Instrument,
the company that created
all of these cool demos that
are surrounding us.
Hi, Violet.
How are you doing?
VIOLET PENA: Hi I'm great.
How are you guys doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
Very excited to have you here.
Yesterday, we got to
interview John Brown.
He told us a little
bit about all the demos
from a high point of view.
What demos did you work on?
VIOLET PENA: So I was focused,
just on the Emotobooth,
using the Vision API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool--
which was an amazing demo.
MARK MANDEL: We love this demo.
VIOLET PENA: Great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Lots of fun.
Tell us a little bit,
how was the experience?
How did you come up with the
idea and how did it work?
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
So we were looking for something
to showcase the Google Cloud
Vision API.
And we were looking
for something
that we could fit into
the conference experience
as, like, a really
fun, you know, break
from more technical sessions
and those kinds of experiences.
So we were trying
to figure out how
to highlight its
different capabilities
or how to make that
fun and interactive.
And so we ended up
landing on looking
at facial recognition,
which is one
of the attributes
of the Vision API.
And so we started getting
really great results
with facial recognition
and sentiment analysis.
And so then, we ended
up with this photo booth
that you walk into.
We help you make
different faces,
conjure up different emotions.
And then, we analyze
the points on your face
and your different
anatomical features,
and then we tell you
about what emotions you're
displaying in that photo.
MARK MANDEL: So was there a
particular part of the demo
that you specifically worked on?
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
I was focused on the front end.
So everything that you
see in the displays,
I had a large hand in.
And then, I have
some coworkers who
are more focused on the
back-end and infrastructure
sides of stuff.
And so that was vital
to actually kicking off
all the analysis and experience
after the photo is taken.
So that was hooking
up the camera
to getting everything
to run properly
and getting all the
back-end processing
to happen so that we can get
your beautiful photo to you.
MARK MANDEL: So you did
a lot of the animation
and, like, the display
up on the screen
that you actually see
as you walk around?
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That's awesome.
VIOLET PENA: There was a lot
of just cycling back and forth
between me and the
designers about, oh, well,
what if we tweak this
color and that opacity,
and change those timings?
And so it was really,
really amazing.
MARK MANDEL: It looks great.
It looks really, really great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
a couple of things
that I really like.
One of them is, kind of,
subtle, but actually-- so
that aura that surrounds
you surrounds only the
faces that you can actually see.
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
the picture with you
and three more people-- I
think you were in that picture.
Maybe not.
But there were four
girls in the picture,
and only one is looking forward.
The others are
looking backwards.
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
[INAUDIBLE] highlight
of that single person
looking at the camera.
How does that work?
VIOLET PENA: So the way that
we've had the experience work
is that we want this colorful
visual treatment on the photo,
but we didn't want to
cover up people's faces.
And so that's how we were also
bringing in the hexagon motif
into the whole thing, right?
Draw a hexagon around the
faces that you find, but then,
of course, it only
finds one face.
It doesn't know if it's a person
if it can't see your face.
So that's how, sometimes, we
ended up with, like you saw,
the three people
are turned around
and one person is
facing forward.
That's the only face it finds.
So it only draws a
hexagon around there,
and it analyzes the
emotions from that one face.
So we actually also
had some group shots
where one person
wouldn't be ready,
and so just totally by accident,
they would be looking away
or-- in our testing,
someone was sneezing
while the photo was taken,
and so her head was down.
And so it drew a
hexagon around, like,
the other people in the
picture, and then she was, like,
covered up by the color.
Yeah.
Yeah, so [LAUGHTER]
that happens.
MARK MANDEL: But
no, I really like
that as, like-- it's just a
really cool idea for using
Vision API for, like,
being able to recognize,
OK, these are the things
that we want to focus on.
And so here are the faces.
So we're going to draw
around that and frame that,
because we know where
they are in the picture.
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
Something else really funny that
happened with face detection,
though-- and this wasn't
a bug-- kind of a bug,
but it was just really,
really funny to me.
Some people here
have security badges
with photos of them on it.
MARK MANDEL: Oh. [CHUCKLE]
VIOLET PENA: And so it
didn't happen to all of them,
but to, maybe,
about half of them.
I guess the light
made it clear enough.
Like, the flash
was bright enough,
the badges angled forwards,
so it would actually
detect the face on their badge.
And, like, these
are really little.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
VIOLET PENA: Right?
Like, a little photo.
Yeah.
And so most of the people--
it would map-- like,
there is another
face in the photo.
Then, it would zoom
in on that face,
and it was, like, this little
blurry picture on a card.
And so someone was
actually smiling
really big in her
photo on her badge,
and it actually kept
saying, joy, very likely,
for that badge.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
VIOLET PENA: So it was
even sentiment-detecting
in that teeny badged photo.
So I think it's hilarious
when stuff like that happens.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I really like it.
Cool.
John also mentioned
that apparently, there
were hot dogs involved.
Could you tell us a little bit
more about what's going on?
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
So you're not going to see any
hot dogs in the product today.
But that was part of the
journey as we were figuring out
what the experience should be.
So, kind of, close to the
beginning, we were, like, well,
a photo booth would be
great, because, you know,
conferences have a photo booth.
But, like, we're
analyzing photos,
so let's do something with that.
So we were trying to figure out
what the photo booth should do,
and the Vision API has
so many options of things
that you can try to analyze.
And so one of the options
is label detection,
and it can tell you what
a photo is of, in general.
So, like, you pass
in a photo of a farm,
and it will give you
labels about what
it would classify the photo
as, in confidence scores.
And so we were trying
to leverage that.
And so we were
thinking, like, well,
what if we gave people props?
And then, we could
get labels going.
So like, if you have a hot
dog, for instance, then--
MARK MANDEL: Which
is something I often
do-- I just have a hot dog.
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
So we were printing
out foam core props.
This was, like, a-- however
many-- four-foot-long hot dogs,
or something--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There
were no real hot dogs?
VIOLET PENA: No.
No actual, because those
would be a little bit small.
But we were printing out,
like, a huge dog, a boom box--
we were trying to do
landmarks, so we had a sphinx--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
VIOLET PENA: --this big,
Eiffel Tower, stuff like that.
So we were trying
to do that, maybe.
So if you have a hot dog
or, like, a slice of pizza,
maybe it'll change the
background of the photo
to put you and your
group in a restaurant,
or something like that.
So we were playing
around with that,
and it just got too hairy,
because as of right now,
anyway, it doesn't
detect specific objects
and say, like, oh,
I see a hot dog at,
you know, this
pixel by that pixel.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
VIOLET PENA: It just tells
you what the whole image,
in general, is of.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
VIOLET PENA: So if you send
it the whole image of people,
even if they're
holding a hot dog,
it'll say the top
guess is group setting
or-- photo shoot,
actually, was the guess
it was giving us a lot.
And we were, like, oh,
that's not very interesting.
Come on.
So yeah, we were trying
to slice up the image
and send through little parts.
But it was taking a
long time, because we
had to keep sending
more small images
and checking those results.
Yeah and so at some
point we were just like,
oh, I don't know if this
is going to work right now.
But then, we had such
other amazing stuff
to dig into that, I think,
ended up being really, really
successful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is a very cool demo.
Are there any other ideas
that you would like to share?
Like, oh, yeah, we
thought about this-- other
than the hot dogs-- and it
did not work, or something.
VIOLET PENA: [LAUGHTER] Right.
Yeah.
Like I said, we
also had landmarks.
And so something that we were
throwing around a little bit
was-- so if you
have landmarks, we
wanted to almost make
postcard treatments.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
VIOLET PENA: So like if you're
walking around with the Eiffel
Tower and it's in your photo,
then the visual treatment
we do-- it puts the city
of Paris behind you,
and then we have a "Greetings
from Paris" across the front.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
I like that.
VIOLET PENA: So we
were doing that,
and we were trying
to figure out,
like, OK, so if one person
has the Statue of Liberty,
and one person has the Arc de
Triomphe, what happens then?
Where are we putting them?
In what country and what city?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
VIOLET PENA: So we were--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Vegas? [LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah.
I like that-- that's good.
VIOLET PENA: That's actually--
we never thought of that.
That could have been our
default for when you're
mixing really weird stuff.
MARK MANDEL: (LAUGHING)
It's just Vegas.
VIOLET PENA: Yeah,
probably Vegas. [LAUGHTER]
So that was really fun.
That was another route
that we, kind of, started
going down, playing with that.
Or maybe, like, we layer
backgrounds together
or we combine city names,
like, "Welcome to New Paris,"
or something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, that
would be really cool.
VIOLET PENA: I mean, that
would have been really fun.
Maybe we'll do some of that,
just as a little fun side
project.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That'd be awesome.
Let's see what you
build for GCP next year.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
very excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: This
has been awesome.
Thank you so much.
JOHN BROWN: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
so much for taking the time
to talk to us.
VIOLET PENA: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
VIOLET PENA: Thanks I having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
VIOLET PENA: Bye.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're here
again with, again, someone
working for Instrument,
this amazing company that
created the very cool demos
that are surrounding us today
at GCP Next.
We have Nick
Tzaperas-- Tzaperas?
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Cool. [CHUCKLE] He worked
specifically on the QueryIt!
demo, right?
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, Nick.
How are you doing?
NICK TZAPERAS: Doing good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Could you
tell us a little bit about you,
what you do at
Instrument, and then
how is it that someone came
up with this cool idea?
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
Well, at Instrument, I'm a
back-end developer and, kind
of all over the place.
We have a lot of front-end
talent at Instrument,
a lot of graphic designers
and front-end developers.
So anything that's at
all dev-ops or writing
SQL for BigQuery, that
kind of back-end thing--
I'd hop on that.
And I think the
idea for BigQuery
came from our creative
talent at Instrument,
and just trying to mimic
the Family Feud style,
like, create a
game for BigQuery.
That's the team that
I work on, and that's
what we try to do-- create
interactive experiences
with technology.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So you mentioned that you
are a back-end engineer.
Have you ever
written SQL before?
Is that something that you
put in your resume, or--
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
I've definitely
run a lot of SQL.
A few jobs ago, I was
actually somewhat of a DVA.
It was a small company.
So there was a lot of things
that needed to be done.
And I was running
backups for the database,
running migrations,
and writing SQL
to try to figure out why the
database was running slow,
trying to do performance
optimizations on it.
So pretty familiar with SQL,
going into the BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Did you need to do any of
those, like, making sure
that queries are optimized
and stuff, with BigQuery?
NICK TZAPERAS: A little bit.
Yeah.
We were trying to make
an interactive game,
and, you know, any good
interactive experience
won't have you sitting there for
a minute, waiting for the query
to finish.
And we're trying to
support a lot of features,
so-- some questions like,
what was the most talked about
rapper on /r/music
in the last year?
We wanted people to be able to
type in Kanye or Kanye West,
or J dash Z or space Z,
and have it all work.
And so the databases that
we were using had aliases,
and trying to pull
in all the aliases
for every single musician
and searching Reddit for that
was taking, like, a minute.
And the game's slow
in chugging along,
because you type in your
answer and you're sitting there
for a minute, just
waiting and waiting.
And the BigQuery
interface actually
had some-- like, when
you run your query,
it has an explanation
of where time was spent
and shows you portions of your
query that took a long time.
And I was able to use that to
figure out what to, kind of,
cut out of the query to make
it run faster, to make it
a faster-paced trivia game.
MARK MANDEL: Was this
your first experience
working with BigQuery?
NICK TZAPERAS: Oh, yeah.
Definitely.
Just-- yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But
pretty easy to pick up?
It wasn't difficult in any way?
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
I just jumped into
the interface.
I think almost
the entire time, I
was just using the
interface that was created.
A coworker of mine--
eventually, we got up to-- we
were trying to create
as many questions
as possible, because
that's something else.
We want people to be able
to stick around and play
a few times and not see the
same questions over and over.
So we were shooting
for 200 questions.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
VIOLET PENA: So eventually,
once we got up to that mini
[INAUDIBLE]-- just a huge
database of questions,
it became impractical
to manage by hand.
And so we were
using the API more.
But when I first started
playing with BigQuery,
it was just with the interface.
And Felipe-- he is actually
using some of his databases.
He just sent me some
links to his databases,
and they showed
up on my account,
and we just started
playing with them.
Yeah.
And then, yeah, just clicking
on tables-- and you can click,
see all the columns
in the schema,
and just writing SQL, and
looking around at the data.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I'm quite curious to know
what the process was for coming
up with those questions.
NICK TZAPERAS: [LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: I know
you had the data sets.
Did they, like,
pose the question
to you, and then
you were, like, OK,
now I have to answer this
question, using the BigQuery,
and then you'd go off and answer
it and just rinse and repeat?
Or what happened?
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
That was the most
challenging thing--
was coming up with questions,
because the data sets
themselves aren't that
exciting, honestly.
It's just Reddit comments,
and GitHub commit pushes.
So trying to create a question
that would make you laugh
but was also still
possible to actually query
was pretty challenging.
And the process evolved a lot.
At first, we had a writer
that was just coming up
with fun questions,
and a strategist--
they were both working on
just writing questions,
and then I would
go and see which
of the questions that
they wrote were actually
possible to search.
And this is before I even really
knew the data sets that well.
And so I'd take the questions
and have to actually go
see-- is this queryable?
I'm not sure-- and go
try it out and realize,
oh, no, there's actually, kind
of, a limited things that we
can search.
So then, we changed it up to
where we reversed it towards,
like, OK, we're more
familiar with the data sets.
Here's what we can query.
Try to make these interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Ah.
I see.
NICK TZAPERAS: I think the
one that we had the most fun
with was pulling tags
from Freebase, which is,
kind of, like a big database.
It's just a bunch of
connected-- you can go from,
like, Tom Cruise was
an actor in this movie,
and this movie was
done in 1983, and then
1983 is the year
that this happened.
It's just this big,
connected graph database.
And there are certain tags
in there, so you can pull up,
like-- we have one question
about which 80s movie was
talked about most on
/r/movies last year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Mm.
Nice.
NICK TZAPERAS: And so we
were able to get, like,
movies that were made
in the 80s, musicians,
food ingredients, breeds of
dogs, and things like that.
And so I think discovering that
made a lot of fun questions,
because then, you're
able to just search--
a lot of these databases
like Reddit are just text.
It's just people typing text.
There's no structure, and
so getting a structured data
set, and then being able to
search for certain categories
within Reddit-- that, I think,
created a lot of fun questions.
MARK MANDEL: The combination
of data sets really [INAUDIBLE]
be able to do some
interesting things.
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
Which was also tricky, because
that creates a huge query.
Because you're, kind of, pulling
all of these movies over here,
searching all of these
comments over here for them,
and it just multiplies.
You know, you have, like,
millions of comments in Reddit
that you're searching
for, and thousands
of movies you're searching for
within each individual comment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because
something important to mention
is the fact that you really
don't know what people are
going to write as an answer.
So you cannot even cast
a solution or anything.
So it's like, every single time
that someone answers something,
you're actually processing
the whole millions
and millions of data.
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
No.
That's exactly what we want
to do with the experience.
There was some talk about doing
a multiple-choice versus typing
in an answer, and we
definitely, definitely
wanted to try having
users type in an answer.
Because then, you get
that feel of actually
hitting BigQuery live.
And you can type in
whatever you want,
and it'll go search for
it, versus multiple-choice.
If you have like five
choices and you choose E,
you're, kind of,
thinking, well, maybe they
pulled those answers yesterday,
and it took five hours
to run the query.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You can totally fake it.
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah, you
can, kind of, fake it.
But I think it turned out
great, where people can actually
tell-- when they
type in the answer
and they can type in absolutely
whatever they want, it shows
the SQL, and the thing
he types in is in there,
and then goes and
runs the query live.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've got
to say, I actually got
a question which was, what
was the most popular kitchen
utensil during the last
month on Wikipedia.
And I went with spork, which
is my favorite kitchen utensil.
And the query actually worked.
I got a zero.
NICK TZAPERAS: Oh. [LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So yeah, I don't
think it was prepared for.
Like, I don't think
that lots of people
think about sporks very often.
MARK MANDEL: Apart from
you, quite clearly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I like sporks.
NICK TZAPERAS: I don't
think I've ever cooked
with-- I've used a spork.
I don't think I've cooked
with one, though. [CHUCKLE]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I have a couple questions
about your questions.
The first one is, what
is your favorite question
that you've written?
NICK TZAPERAS: I think it was
the comic book character one.
There was a lot of-- I mean,
there are so many of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
NICK TZAPERAS: We're pulling
the database, finding
a list of all comic book
characters-- there are,
like 6000 or something.
And so it's, kind of,
fun to see random people
come up and just type in some
random comic book character
that I've never heard
of-- go and look them up
and it's some side character in
some Marvel comic, or whatever.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is cool.
NICK TZAPERAS: There was
one guy, specifically.
Me and John-- we were trying
to get people to play.
We said, hey, you want to play?
He said, no, no, no.
We're, like, OK, OK.
And then, we go up and we play.
And he sees the first question
is the comic book character
question.
And he immediately says,
oh, no-- and he runs out--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Now, I want to play.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK TZAPERAS: He
thought it was going
to be, like, maybe some kind of
Trivial Pursuit-type questions.
And he saw the comic book one
and he immediately was, like,
oh, Batman.
You know, he was ready to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
What about-- what was the
hardest query to write?
What was the question that
came with the hardest query?
NICK TZAPERAS: I
think I would say
it's the ones that we dropped.
There were a few questions
that I was working really hard
to get right, and it
was just the data itself
that wasn't quite working out.
So there was a few,
like, top musician
questions, which I
think is in there,
but we, kind of, tweaked it.
That one-- I was trying to do
the thing where you could type
in Kanye or Kanye
West or-- you could
type in Lennon, John Lennon.
There are a few aliases
for certain musicians
that I want people to
be able to type in.
And it was really slow, trying
to support all the aliases,
and even some of the aliases
in the database were wrong.
So there are many, many,
many, many different occasions
where we're trying to
pull musicians or actors,
and someone completely
unexpected comes up.
So like, pulling top
musicians, John Cleese
came up, because I think
he was in a musical.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, he was.
He was in a musical.
NICK TZAPERAS: And so,
technically, he's a musician.
And then, he was the top
answer for the question.
He was the most talked-about
musician, technically,
when we wrote this
query, in /r/music,
because his alias is "friend" in
the database that we're using.
And so whenever we
saw the word, friend,
it thought that they were
talking about John Cleese.
And so he was, like,
number one, by far.
He was, like, number one, John
Cleese, number two, Kanye West.
I said, well, we're going
to have to figure out
how to do this right.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
sure John Cleese was
very happy about that.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah I guess
the biggest problem, then,
was really just, like, yeah, you
need a dataset that is clean,
and you have ambiguity there.
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
Because a lot of times,
you don't actually
know what-- I mean,
we're not doing
natural language processing
on the Reddit comments.
So it's trying to pull
data out of the comments
where you know what they're
specifically talking about.
So trying to come
up with questions
or write questions to where
there's no ambiguity about what
a user might be talking
about on Reddit-- that
was the really challenging part.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, are there
any other questions
that you'd like to share?
Like, something that was really
cool and you'd like to share?
NICK TZAPERAS: I think the
speed of it-- a lot of the data
sets for GitHub, we're
doing all the time.
So some of the
questions that got cut,
just because I guess they
weren't quite family-friendly,
was, like, what programming
language cusses the most.
And there's a list of, maybe, 20
different cuss words that we're
searching for with GitHub.
And I think that was
the first I went to,
because it was just so fun.
Everyone at the
office was really
having fun with that one.
And also, the poop emoji one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
was the language?
NICK TZAPERAS:
Oh, you know what?
I think--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
want to say it's C,
because it's so hard to write.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK TZAPERAS: C
was surprisingly--
I think they were
surprisingly happy people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Java.
I'm gonna go with Java.
NICK TZAPERAS: I think it was.
Java was up there.
But it was the speed of it.
Like, it went through
every single event
that happened in GitHub for
the past, like, five years.
Like, just commits,
pushes, issue comments,
opening an issue, closing
an issue, like all of it--
it went through all of
it in, like, 10 seconds.
I mean, that's when I
first started using it.
That was a big wow
moment-- just the speed
that you have accessible to you.
Because doing a Google
search, obviously,
is super, super fast, and
that's always been impressive.
But now that it's been
kind of turned around
and now you have the ability
to use that infrastructure
to search whatever you
want within seconds,
that moment was
really, really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us.
NICK TZAPERAS: Yeah.
No problem.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you so
much to John, Violet, and Nick,
for those amazing interviews.
We have a bunch of links
in the Show Notes, too,
so you can see pictures of
demos, videos, and so on.
They're totally worth
having a look at,
so just go there and enjoy.
And now, we're going to go
for the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
question of the week
is about Deployment Manager.
And as I said,
it's the first time
we talk about it at all, so
I think it's probably worth
mentioning, a little bit,
what Deployment Manager is.
MARK MANDEL: So
Deployment Manager
is a way to programmatically
and declaratively, basically,
say what infrastructure
you want to spin up
on Google Cloud Platform.
So maybe you want a
whole bunch of machines,
maybe you want to
Kubernetes Cluster,
or maybe you want a
Cloud SQL database.
And so you can write
these YAML files,
send them out through
Deployment Manager,
and it will create that for
you and [INAUDIBLE] away.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So it's, kind of, like
Kubernetes configuration
files, where you describe your
architecture of your cluster.
But it's a little bit-- it's
a higher level, where you're
describing the architecture
of your Google Cloud Platform
project in general.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
There's actually--
for some people
that may have used it
before-- there's also
Terraform by HashiCorp.
It's, kind of, the same idea.
Terraform works across
different platforms,
and Cloud Deployment Manager is
just for Google Cloud Platform.
So what was the question, then?
MARK MANDEL: So the question
that got asked, actually,
was by one of our Google
Cloud Platform users,
who was asking how you parse
in variables to Deployment
Manager.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, interesting.
MARK MANDEL: So if you're
writing your script,
you've got, say, a YAML
file, but maybe you
want three instances of
something in, like, testing,
but you want 20
instances in production.
How can you do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
how do you do it?
MARK MANDEL: How do you do that?
So it's actually
reasonably straightforward.
One of the things that
Deployment Manager supports
is a thing called, templates.
And basically, they're
Jinja templates.
If you've ever used Python,
it's a standard templating thing
for Python.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I know those.
MARK MANDEL: You know those?
Yeah?
Wonderful.
And so rather than just
writing a YAML file,
you write a template with these
variable placeholders in them,
and then you can populate them.
Now, where it got a little
confusing for the person
in question was, they
figured, oh, maybe I
can parse in the variables
on the command line.
But instead of doing that,
actually, what you do is,
you end up doing a YAML file
where you import the template.
And then, when you
import the template,
you use that import
as a custom resource.
And then, when you
do that, you can
parse in variables
inside that YAML file.
So they just become, like,
child elements within the YAML.
We'll have it in the Show Notes,
so you can see the examples.
But the templates are
super, super powerful
because you have the full
power of Jinja behind it.
And then, you can simply just
parse in whatever variables
you need within
that configuration.
So you might have a
test configuration
for your testing
servers, and then, maybe,
a prod version of
that as well for when
you want the 20, rather
than the 3, 4, or 5.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
I'm looking at some of the
configuration files now,
and, yeah, they actually remind
me a lot of queue configs.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
If you look at the
configuration files,
they match up exactly
with the APIs--
the REST APIs that we have to be
able to create stuff and delete
stuff.
So it's directly
in line with that.
They're pretty
straightforward to use
once you get the hang of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, I think that
that's all for today.
But before that, maybe
it's time to, first of all,
thank our listeners and
remind them how to contact us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So if they want to
reach us on e-mail,
it's hello@GCPPodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If they want
to reach is on our website,
it's GCPPodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: If they want
to reach us on Twitter,
it's GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
@GCPPodcast, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If they want
to reach is on Google Cloud,
it's +GCPPodcast.
MARK MANDEL: If they want
to reach us on Reddit,
it's /r/GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
now, I think we're done?
Or--
MARK MANDEL: If they want
to reach us on Slack,
it's hash #Podcastchannel
inside the Slack community.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
always forget that one.
MARK MANDEL: You do.
Are you going to
be anywhere special
in the next couple of weeks?
Any new speaking
engagements coming up?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm actually very excited about
going to Craft Conf in Budapest
at the end of the month.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
I'm very, very
excited about that.
My first time in Hungary.
So if any of our
listeners is somewhere
around Hungary and
Budapest, let us know.
I'd be very happy to
say, hi, and maybe I
can bring your a t-shirt.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
That sounds like fun.
At the end of the month, I
am heading to Kentucky, here
in the USA.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Where
bourbon comes from.
MARK MANDEL: I have
never been there before.
So I will be going to
the Vector Conference.
I'm hosting a gaming
roundtable there,
talking about how
Cloud changes the game.
That is on the 30th of April.
And then, I will be heading
over to Louisville on May 2nd,
to go to the local GDG and
talk to them that Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Sounds fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's going to be great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Have you been there?
MARK MANDEL: I have
never been to Kentucky.
I'm, kind of, excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: New state.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, thank you, Mark, for
another amazing episode.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very
much for joining me yet again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
talk to next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]